Oh Mike, je reçois encore une fois, c'est juste s'il vous plaît,
prenez une seconde pour changer lequel
des Richardson a été
engagé de manière inattendue, alors nous allons bien nous occuper de vous.
Landon va changer le baril pour moi.
point ouais qu'est-ce que c'est ouais qu'est-ce que tu
penses pouf c'est une [ __ ] d'âme oh c'est non
c'est un [ __ ] de rouleau à pâtisserie gros Fanny
Cradock tu fais avec ça ça va me faire un
gâteau et chanter une chanson qui me permettra de
[ __ ] de bougies je viens ici  pour une
[ __ ] de fusillade, écrivez un costume approprié
avec des hommes appropriés, ce que le colonel
Custer Geronimo vous savez parce que
vous étiez trop occupé à épingler un
[ __ ] de coup ferme qui n'est pas un
[ __ ] de nonces pour un homme que vous
ne faites pas, [ __ ] de nazis  tu baises ta femme va t'en aller
va te faire [ __ ] appelle toi un [ __ ] de
gangster porte plainte c'est un [ __ ] de
canapé
comme un branleur occidental [ __ ] d'embarras
une fois que les boulons sont foutus lave la boîte
sur Donna Rana de ton frère est juste
sincèrement déçue  avec une leçon